new special now explain it to us because
I want to get a lot of stuff but just
let me have a lot of talk about Nellie
but just start off first with explaining
35 minutes of your hacen ated with your
okay so I want I'm following in your
footsteps yeah okay I like as far as
like social media well also just like I
lose some bees
I like that he's gonna let he's
releasing this on YouTube yeah so yeah
talked abut a little bit about last time
but I'm learning from the young ones yes
yes yes yes yes I'm here for you man
yeah yeah I just did a I released a new
special on my youtube and it's uh it's
like 35 minutes no material nothing
planned I just did you know crowd work I
just went up there and rift with the
audience I sorry she's very good thank
you and thank you funny it's funny man
yeah and thank God that audience in DC
which is a great spot shout out DC him
oh yeah D say were there to play us do
this yeah they were cool with it I got a
great [ __ ] audience yeah you're good
yeah I thought that what else is
brilliant that I thought that you did is
you release it the same day Chappelle
special came out had to well I think
most people would go hold up the
greatest of all time is really special
yeah I'm gonna wait two weeks nah you
went even boy get the opening the video
goes you know bells drama special dude
you should be yours right same day he
does it let's see what happened yeah
that was good yeah we didn't know we
were gonna take that comedy is like
Chappelle was like everything was so hot
and then it would go yeah oh you watch
that I've seen Andrew Schultz and then
was like it was like this [ __ ] Herc
yeah it was like an album drop yeah I
was weird many people drop albums back
in the day knows yeah you listen to
Kanye's then you listen to fit these or
you listen to whatever like multiple
albums will come out on the same day I'm
thinking about taking my greatest hits
like after just like four hours of
[ __ ] I love this going taking my
greatest hits redoing them shooting a
meal and putting them up oh you need oh
oh you mean at 50 doing like the penguin
impression tractor yeah oh that is
interesting cuz I'd actually be curious
to see like I just did I'd like to try
them now yeah but kind of outgrown them
but you do like can you but what if you
took the special you shotgun to I could
do it what about the question is just
give me a little weird it's just a
little weird your age to go back
Seinfeld digital did it yeah yeah I feel
like I could do it and I feel like I
could add stuff to it and make it
contemporary sort
you know I'm like that makes sense yeah
do it but I would like to see the
comparison too but that's just a fun
thing to do it's a fun things I'm gonna
do it and you just put it out on YouTube
yeah the beauty of it yeah like you have
control when you drop that you do
whatever the [ __ ] you want but I yeah
yeah you're like the you're suppose you
have special on Showtime where else all
right
what's showtime and then just Amazon and
the same thing you know and but but you
never grow up you get those back now
yeah so yeah I mean you could dice all
that up and put behind if getting back
they are they're owned by comedy
dynamics but Brian Volk wise to butter
your mind so yes I'm sure he'll give you
clip yeah you know yeah but for sure
yeah yours has been going well because
because it's crazy man like we're over
half a million now I think we put out a
little less than a week
oh it's in the mail dog I told you that
I take how it you must be feeling so
good it's so well it was cool it was
them it was the thing that's been most
shared by people for me I think because
the the world we live in now it's not so
overproduce and it's like yeah it's it's
your talents at the highest level where
I think when what when you get a special
you know that comics done that set yeah
100 thousand times who knows exactly
he's doing no matter who it is
yeah so I think by you going up there
and you're like now let's see what
happens
yeah I think that's why people [ __ ] with
it cuz in profits it's a lot yeah I need
the stakes are high yeah and also like
so many people [ __ ] thinking like if
you guys felt that way like I just so
many think pieces about everything like
there's that we were just talking before
his to think piece about the popeyes
chicken it's like it's just constant
think pieces and and I knew when
Chappelle was gonna drop there's gonna
be a million think pieces so you know
what's funny about that is it in in
sitcoms yeah there was a who the [ __ ]
was a Trey Parker the guy yeah and I
think he was saying he said what
happened is I'm sorry if I'm quoting if
it was him but I think it was he said
sitcoms for a long time were a 12 year
old would come in and say a snarky line
mm-hmm that a bunch of 35 year old
professional writers took a week to
relay and and so she'd come and say
something that obviously a
twelve-year-old wouldn't say but haha
that's the funny yeah after a while
audiences get hip to that formula yeah
that's that kind of comedy gets dated
yeah and comedy like anything else
starts to get dated then all of a sudden
somebody comes in and does something new
like an improv show or whatever it might
be The Sopranos comes along everybody
was like wait a minute you got a monitor
it was [ __ ] having panic attacks yeah
well as the game right it changes for
the better a hundred percent for the
better it just things things do go out
of style after all the first thing about
that today I was thinking about how you
can at my age you know look you can get
people to laugh it becomes a bit of a
bag of tricks but I'm interested in
doing something people haven't done
before I'm still interested in doing
that yeah I want to do something like
when I do this long monologue about my
dad you know being a tyrannical piano
teacher it's good it's moving into other
territory yeah there's room for that now
cuz it gets somewhat traumatic when
people [ __ ] love it yeah they love
watching something theatrical or
something different sometimes yeah once
you have people's attention you could
take them penniless I think that's what
we learned to chapelle us right like
like if like Chappelle's ago you know
don't get me wrong he's living go right
and and like if you but if you watch his
special it's the most pleasing thing to
watch because you could just listen to
it yeah you actually might not laugh
that much but you and your interest to
the best order of our generation the
best storyteller and every little piece
that he gives us has a cool fun ending
and you learn something and you learn
some and he's also articulating feelings
that people have like he's the first
he's the first major comedian I think to
like really come out against the PC [ __ ]
like like but he's the biggest of the
big
go do it obviously Rogan has done it I
own different Platon Ilyich Chapelle but
man different right he goes what's
everyone sensitive about check this out
right and like to be honest that was I
mean last time we spoke I was here
probably right before I drop views yeah
that was the point of views right views
from the SIS the last special is just
like I'm going to specifically target
these things you're not supposed to talk
about [ __ ]
I'm grabbing [ __ ] me too you got a
trouble for some of those right do you
know what I didn't really like I've got
more way more trouble now that people
know me than when I first dropped that
because the point of that was like yo we
can laugh at [ __ ] Dubourg
honey yeah kid like uber has an abortion
bit yeah yeah I'm not gonna go into it
we were watching it like this ever
yeah and I said I talked to him we just
did that that charity I know I said bro
I go yeah I go bro yeah well you're the
only one that can get away with that
[ __ ] he goes no I'm not no I'm not all
of us can and all of us should because
it's only you're talking about 3% of the
[ __ ] who are the loudest yo social
so that's a narrative I don't go ahead
no so that's the thing this is this
really important about you know
basically what what I want to show with
this vessel right like anytime or at
least a specialist cuz I feel like I
gotta address something that's happening
right how many have you done and you so
I had the first one that was only like
15 it was part of like an hour but that
was for for one that's why I did the
four different club tonight chopped it
up yeah and then I have use from assist
that I was the one that's really going
against the PC [ __ ] and then the crowd
work special now and what I want to show
in the crowd work special is like I got
a very diverse audience I probably got
the most diverse audience in comedy
right and the point of the crowd were
special was I'm gonna make fun of every
different race gender religion in the
crowd and they're gonna laugh and
they're gonna show you that we could
laugh at ourselves yes it it's it it's
literally five girls with short hair on
the internet that are making everything
a big deal but it has in no way the
general opinion it's not the opinion
here's the thing look at how we already
offended if you watch it all that we
have angles from the back you can't be
offended on behalf of the Indian guy the
front row because he's laughing
it's brilliant shot because you see from
the back view point you see what they're
seeing and they see what yours you are
comic you man an audience member when he
wants to like when he's roasting like
there's there's four black girls and he
saw them out double date he's like he's
I got from Nigeria's like I'm supposed
to know that [ __ ] races if I was like oh
you're from Nigeria but it but third eye
and then the Mexica on the back who does
I don't mean get all your [ __ ] away this
just references you know this is
purposely the man and girl in the back
doesn't like kids
yeah right that would you watch you have
kill my this [ __ ] knock out of
the park yeah this Mexican chick says
she's not my kids so I was like it's
four million SIA minutes it's
specifically done why but by the way
neck skin it Colombian Indian they
and that's American by the way when you
see Americans work together I ever
worked in a [ __ ] like you've been in
a five army when I worked in a bank yeah
anywhere you work in a [ __ ]
restaurant that's what Americans work
really well together and they're from
all different but I make fun of each
other non-stop here the reason why you
get well you know you're allowed to do
this and people are gonna enjoy it and I
say all the time with if you just pay
attention to social media which so talk
to violent and the loudest [ __ ] is on
there ya can try to you know this blah
blah blah but when that girl your short
hair that girl short hair all it cares
and they're not a single or fatty skin
yeah we're males wet can't get [ __ ]
guys who can't get laid right and fat
girls that can't put their hair in a
ponytail correct those are the two
groups of people to have opinion if you
don't shut up [ __ ] up and they dye their
hair purple and all this kind of [ __ ]
[ __ ] they are that is being and they
have these big opinions about [ __ ]
everything but no one really cares no
ears but they're loud it's on the
internet because they're the same size
as everyone else in life they're way
bigger it's also a lot of media but not
really but but the thing is is you put
off both you guys know all three of us
know is when you're on the road you've
seen real people in Oroville and spoke
in washes and [ __ ] working miracle
Salt Lake City shootin easy Washington
DC they're good people who are not
prejudiced don't know that but that
Butler Toma Joy there and you see they
don't they don't give a file my
favorites not about like our great
people we're in LA right now and I live
in New York and it's like you know LA
New York like liberal elites they love
to do this thing where they like make
call like people in the south and my
conservative such racist right but like
every time someone calls the police on a
black person for barbecuing or like
selling water so where where does that
happen always only knew where the [ __ ]
does that happen we knew Alabama no
Yeah right it's New York City its New
York Mississippi right never Texas you
know I do think that a lot of is coming
out of elite academic institutions and a
lot of the media for people who've never
really had they they've liked one things
that somebody said yes to one of those
woke super woke white journalists said
do you know anybody who works with their
hands or anybody in the military
is there anybody your phone whose smoke
yeah who works with their hands
count and she was like and it that's
that's the thing to me they're
completely out there was all this uproar
yeah but anyone that you taught anybody
talk to advice my fellow [ __ ] them sorry
about yourself a member of Isis and me
chosen rock star movement got him is
that right Oh Bob they're so self or I
forget how much money and then all the
we went hold up I'll we're telling
secrets now and the interesting but also
like they used to be so cutting [ __ ]
corny do't vice to me was a bunch of
dudes from [ __ ] Maine they moved to
New York City because they thought they
were the coolest person in Maine and
then when I moved to Brooklyn they were
like oh now I'm here I'm one one's a
proud part of it he's like the main
Gavin yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh good what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]